tighten the screws hit that much better
tonight
Green firing away back-to-back rays
from Zurich about Auckland guards got to
I mean I wouldn't be remiss if I didn't
I mean you look at Danny Green your
generation
ball fake shot doesn't go gotta get on
the glass against Cavaliers and now
taken away is Greenlee past Lowry to the
trailing Leonard and the
see bucket respond to the pantry check
it in oh gee here's green a good place
luck Danny gray for Barnes which
to go
that was denied
that's stepping up big time down the
stretch of this ballgame that's
impressive right
6:9 the five-day miles the Jamie Gries
green those drives banks in a great body
control over Kemba Walker like England
what Ingram did that was yeah I'm glad
he got bigger to this penalty great job
by Green here's letter rising kicking
green the thread
good hands by Danny Green ripped up all
up to cry Leonard he knows who his buddy
to Santa Tony was right there and you
talk about a guy's gonna make that
shawls moving he's getting easy quick
touches so he should be getting to the
lunch
here's Jimbo Walker off the bow denied
by green lit away the eighth turnover
chase down denial bald everybody's
digging in nobody quits on plays as it
goes on easy buckets the other way Ibaka
can we get into I think you feel like a
stage name rights as it repast stole
away by
Danny grade since of 26 to 27 and as
they put up a total of 65 come on you
could just see against New Orleans will
keep channel that deep grade range from
great speed Morris Torres smart who say
by Lowry how hungry are you search
hungry for a bucket it doesn't go Danny
Green turns fires good in the corner his
van fleet here's Danny Green for the way
yes he did
point five on the clock grown-up
what a play call at the end
Danny Green delivers in the Toronto
Raptors leave Orlando with a win
Isles about he hit two big threes in the
fourth and then this game winner that's
jack
coming off of a season pass
18 the steal by Green
here's an axe from Halifax
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that was a pass somehow gets its way in
the Danny Green with the black Lowry
keeps yamas right there on his hip in
the transition three doesn't go green
finds Ibaka
Ibaka banks it in those are the three
stopped chasing him off the line and
then he just throws it up a dead a combo
able to reel it in deflected here's
green Raptors number ciacco down vers
their intent on getting to the rim as
Harrell gets blocked by de gracia OGN
Adobe
rock again and great pass by tile our
mascot siakam is one of those guys you
want to give it to him in stride great
working on curry made himself a little
space and knocked it down
I've just never seen him post up in the
shot clock for green well defended by
curry
oh boy makes a tough shot nonetheless
salon right outside Danny Green and a
three beats the buzzer with a triple you
can't leave him for a second he handed
107 shooting in the corner Danny Green
sidestep not Drive jack it's a NATO
runner the Raptors have cut it to five
Winslow's does it go so he's missed his
last two after making that's pretty
here's green triggers and Ray damn a
trade the Green Ranger has arrived weeks
not able to reel it in and as Sergio
Scott iolo mention Danny Green facts
from two cr1 come on give me two right
there how about sandy green coming down
burying the free
[Applause]
great well down sod read it get the ball
to the clock and the Raptors have used
it so
in a pocket Nate teens had dribbled
after green pokes it away delight of
distress that right foot was dragging
behind and really not as hidden get his
legs into a shot never he's a rhythm
shooter but that scooped up by Pascal
Chicago
surge 81 68
[Music]
we've done by Alan ears Carol just made
a three championship raptors albeit
they've gotten off to their best start
in franchise history it's all about the
postseason and Danny Green has been in
the postseason before so gotta clean
that up Jackson with a rebound
lead pass holiday pass stole it away
green down a basket starts with the D
and Danny Green doing a good job but
like Kyle Lowry soon as he gets it he
wants up before he's got the streaking
siakam Jackson spinning loses it in the
turnover the 16th here's the act of
numbers Lowry simple game when you find
the hot hand play D get out the run and
every one of those mark is critical
there's grain founded by rivers a good
defender and green made a tough shot
Kenny smells very strong gone hustling
is right now freeze swats it away in
2016 declared quote I am Toronto and
clover
reins on outside knocks down the jump
shot with Kontest by Kawhi Leonard
but the Spurs come up with a steal a
very quiet night for LaMarcus zackham
the Euro step off going out of bounds if
you don't know exactly where it's gonna
go spinning just waiting to come on you
gotta give these guys credit you've got
to give Alvin Gentry Kenneth incredibly
is a great job to get these guys to play
hard beautiful fashion Danny Green
Raptors back up by one what he was
playing with the Lakers hey guarded by
Green Drive so quick Gasol and it's last
touch by New Orlean or as quickly as he
can love that when he's trying to get it
and push the tempo like that green and a
nice move Williams with you know that
the time is now for this team Danny
Green by Drummond scoops it back up
driving loses it green splash
Green drills to 300 Drummond does a
really good job guarding the white legs
it has stands moving his feet Gooch I
can test I was a big-time shot but why
quickly here's Fred driving kitchen
Green Kauai open lines it up got who I
let it made that whole play watch this
pitch defenses in big trouble now
hard triple swing swing clean perfect
but hey pitch it the Oh 809 season
[Applause]
Danny Green fires it up and it goes and
a foul by Toronto X great execution
after a timeout and a flare amount
opposite corner and beautiful delivery
at times he's just not assertive enough
guy who has improved every year that
he's been in the league boy you got to
put a hand up on Danny Green
that's his third three already that'll
be on the night table Tony place save
that one for Friday not that one Danny
Green with his fifth three-pointer of
the night loose ball he created that
there with his presence on the inside
Danny Green chase off the line
and surged back city and in the
it's
in Mayfield goes for the Raptors Jani
green doing a great job a fine
serge ibaka hey from point A to point A
to point B unbelievable speed and how
about this number Mattie
nor lose it
[Applause]
gunshot
Hawaii Lennon we have to find in Pascal
see Graham finds ladies
the corner
and the night
coordinating with it Teno run lead pass
Danny Green to come back selfish play as
Isaac flies by and the Raptors lead by
five great round of applause from the
fans here in Toronto and Lowry lead pass
he norm whips it over to see Aqaba hind
the back diving was Winslow Green to
pile
rebounds eight minutes of action if you
need good hustle that time by Winslow
but a ball gets swung beautiful skip
nice pass by Green get high to 71 tight
nine main rotation taken it goes
right here beautiful pass by pounds
boutique zones
Bertie's Jang has it blocked by Danny
Green who is second among guards in
siakam Miss Rose gang was a little
surprised by this watch this again great
recovery here by Green here's Gasol
Green siakam the three great ball
movement had time seek I'll try to get
downhill here cuz soul finds green his
three and deflected by Butler
flower inside Danny Green close it up in
a flowery just his second field goal
seven points four assists off the
turnover drain throws it up the siakam
and a lead cut to 11 Lowery shot clock
winding down Green's got to get it off
just does and thanks at Hall corner pop
doesn't go and it's rebounded by Green
he's back in there for the Raptors on
the wall returning for Philadelphia
Green fires caps it's a triple now as
Toronto winning the battle on the
backboard and then Danny Green they're
just in rhythm Mabel Simmons
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's plate on a switch by Lowery they
double up
blow off experience brings composure to
the
[Applause]
points in the paint since the third
quarter foot salons hope a greased a
speaker I'm upset with the looks this
Raptor team is getting missed on his
game the solo with a rebound ahead to
Danny Green reverse layup counted to go
Marcus cousins now in double figures
Danny Green launches a 3x good
back-to-back threes but Toronto Danny
Green
head fake three-pointer is good and he
greed with three threes here in the
opening period against Jordan Bell gets
into the paint against the block by now
not Clues and Leonard able of saving
Danny Green for three
Danny Green does it again look here he
just beats him to the ball saves it and
then a desperation three by Green vans
lead to Ibaka blocked by down bears cook
ahead of the pack one man to beat gets
inside blocked by Danny Green
sensational recovering wiring a fan join
the great blocks of green what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content